If you got
okay
diagnosed with a horrible disease night,
I tried to think of a better
way to ask you this question,
which isn't like majorly
depressing because this is,
but if you got diagnosed with the disease
that was going to kill you in a year
or 18 months, what would
you do with those months?
I, so I role play this
all the time. Uh, not,
not because I want to dwell the darkness,
but this is part of the rehearsing
the worst case scenario.
So not only do I rehearse this for myself,
but I try to spend time around
people who are going to die. Uh,
and when I get back to the bay area,
actually want to volunteer in a
hospice center to contend with that.
Uh, there are a few things. So I would,
I would get my affairs in
order relatively quickly.
They're already largely in order so
that my family would be taken care of.
And to be honest,
and there aren't many points in
my life where I could say this,
I would largely keep doing
what I'm doing. Honestly. Uh,
I think that I stopped. For instance,
the tech investing about two years ago,
because I felt like I was replaceable.
I felt like if I in a
sense didn't participate,
there were a hundred other people in
line who are going to step up and write a
check.
And that wasn't a unique opportunity
nor a unique skill that I held to
hopefully put into the world to
benefit people in some way. But, uh,
the, you know, all the
ludicrous experiments,
some more practical than others
and the podcasting and so on.
I feel like I'm putting out
the best work that I can and
okay.
I think I'd keep doing
it and I'd certainly end.
And in the last few years I've,
after reading an essay,
I think it's called the tail
end by Tim Urban on wait,
but why about how effectively by the
time you're 18 and leave the house,
you've spent 80% of the total hours you
were ever, ever spent with your parents.
Uh,
I've reorganized my calendar in my year
to spend a lot more time with my family,
meaning my parents and my brother, and
okay.
I think I'd keep doing what
I'm doing. Honestly until,
until I slipped in and up in a pile of
dust, which is where we're all ended up.
We were ahead. Sooner or later
I was listening. I should,
I keep wanting to do this. I want to,
when I'm listening to certain podcasts,
sometimes I want to just live tweet.
Like when I'm having thoughts about them
and I do it with rogue and sometimes I,
I go, man, I should just be live tweeting
this. Cause sometimes when he had,
who do you have on? Oh when? When
he had Sam Harrison. I was just,
there were so many things that they were
saying that were just hilarious to me.
I don't want us to to, but when you
had Shay Carl on that at one point,
I can't remember his
quote, there was this,
you got to this topic and you know,
you know of what you would do and
it wasn't the same question it was,
but it was somewhere in the same thing.
Maybe it was about money
and got enough money now,
or something along those lines and kind
of at the same time, you know, he says,
he says something like, you know,
just imagine being able to spend
all this time with your family.
And then you said at the
same time, cocaine in horse.
I was like, I want to
be alive. That's cool.
Yeah.
Shane and I had spent a couple of days
together and dusted and which just for
those people that don't have any context,
he's also raised a church of Latter
Day saints, you know, Mormon,
Utah. And uh, so I was
like, okay. Then whores,
which is the nature of my
podcast. I loved that was classic.